foreign
good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack Van
Horn from the University of Virginia and I'm
very proud to welcome you to this edition of our
2022-2023 foundations of biomedical data science
seminar Series this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the College of
Arts and Sciences the school of data science and
through grants from the National Institutes
of General Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data seminar Series has
focused on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to different
themes within the biomedical and Health Sciences
this year's theme is data science and the public
health consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we will enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues promises
opportunities and hurdles associated with
understanding the secondary health effects of
covet 19. these include delayed Health checkups
treatments mental health drug abuse increased
obesity and long lingering health effects
associated with the SARS covid-19 virus indeed our
2022-2023 application cycle has just been extended
to January January 31st and so we encourage
Junior faculty members who are working in areas
such as infectious diseases epidemiology clinical
medicine population Health as well as data science
machine learning AI statistics and other relevant
domains to consider applying we believe this is an
exciting and engaging program with characterizing
the secondary health effects of covid-19
necessitates unique quantitative approaches
but also new multi-disciplinary collaborations
participants selected for the biomedical data
science Innovation lab program will Leverage
The presentations like you're going to hear today
as vital material in their culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be held at
the lodge at St Edwards Park in Seattle Washington
in June of 2023. today I am delighted to welcome
our speaker Dr foreign associate professor of the
Department of industrial and systems engineering
at Virginia Tech Navid earned his PhD in public
policy and working in systems Dynamics from the
State University of New York at Albany in 2011.
he holds a masters of Business Administration and
management from Sharif University of Technology
mechanical engineering also from Sharif
University and prior to joining Virginia
Tech he was a postdoctoral researcher at MIT in
the environmental systems or Engineering Systems
division excuse me navid's research interests
includes systems level thinking and systems
Dynamics modeling of complex social systems with
applications in health policy his work includes
modeling the spread of infectious diseases in his
covid-19 related research papers have appeared in
various journals such as the Lancet bio bioscience
plus computational biology and he has received
considerable media attention by The Washington
Post the New York Times the BBC and Le Monde his
research has been supported by several Federal
organizations such as the NIH the Department of
Defense and the National Science Foundation fun
fact about navis even Joe always watching soccer
and is a fan of persepolis football club and
team melee and he ran his first half marathon
at the age of 44. so there is hope for us all so
thank you Navid and continuing with the 2022-2023
biomedical data science uh seminar series theme
navid's lecture today is entitled enhancing
long-term forecasting learning from covid-19
models and he is going to describe for us that
while much of the effort has gone into building
predictive models um of the covid-19 pandemic some
have argued that early exponential growth combined
with this the stochastic nature of epidemics makes
long-term prediction of contagion trajectories
next to Impossible and he's going to demonstrate
two complementary studies to assess model features
which support better long-term predictions he's
going to describe how he leverages diverse models
contributing to um the CDC repository of covid-19
and US USA death projections to identify factors
associated with increasing the predictability and
accuracy across different projection Horizons
he's then going to introduce a very simple
model which incorporates these features and offers
informative predictions as far as 20 weeks ahead
with accuracy comparable to the best models
in the CDC data set and he is going to argue
that long-term predictive power of multi-wave
covid-19 trajectories is capturing behavioral
responses balancing feedbacks where perceived
risk and death continuously changes transmission
rates throughout the adoption and relaxation
of various non-pharmaceutical interventions
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via YouTube and if you are watching
on YouTube thank you so much for joining us also
our specially selected 22 to 2022 2023 biomedical
science Innovation lab participants and alumni are
encouraged to submit any questions via the chat
feature in their Zoom sessions I will synthesize
these questions and ask them on your behalf during
the last 10 minutes or so of the lecture and
with that welcome Navid we are very much looking
forward to hearing what you have to tell us thank
you very much for the generous introduction it's
a great pleasure to be in this group and
present this work uh so this work is about
um pandemic forecasting and it is a collaborative
work my co-authors are hajjiram on that from MIT
and ranshu from University of Connecticut our
works have been recently funded by the NSF and
in division of mathematical sciences and social
and economic Sciences so we have been all dealing
with the problem of covid-19 and we can easily
remember how things have evolved in the past three
years there have been many puzzling questions and
research has been done you know different research
projects to uncover those and some of the kind of
questions that quickly comes to our mind are about
um estimation of cases that we have in terms of
covid-19 estimating how many people have died you
know providing more accurate estimations then
another layer of questions are about policies
how What policies help to better contain the
disease and these policy questions comes up at
the government level at organizations level you
know many of you in universities uh probably your
universities have been thinking about how to help
keep students safe or even at the individuals you
know many of us have been thinking what type of
actions help to keep our family safer and then
other questions about scenarios things that
are exogenous and may influence the spread of
a disease such as changing the weather but one
other another question which is related to the
other ones is about forecasting can we offer
a better short-term and long-term forecasting
of the spirit of the disease and this is the main
focus of this presentation but it is also related
to the other questions too why do we care about
forecasting actually forecasting has been always
one of the concerns that we have had for making
better decisions in our society just when you
can forecast about things that are going to happen
for your organization for your country you can be
more proactive so there is a strong reason that
forecasting matters makes you smarter in terms
of pandemic it is unavoidable you know we have to
forecast you know we we have emergency measures in
place we want to make a better plan about resource
allocations and make it more efficient allocation
of resources so we want to know how the how the
pandemic will look like a few a month ahead and
and and be prepared for that in terms of Hospital
capacity we like to be prepared for that but even
at the individual level you know wedding plans
or you know attending conferences in person or
online these are things that come up and they
are connected to forecasting so whether or not
you are developing a formal model for forecasting
you at the end you know you you have to predict or
um kind of have some kind of you know expectations
about how the disease will go on to make better
decisions and if you don't have models many times
we end up using our own mental models our best
guesses about how the future will evolve but there
are several problems about pandemic forecasting
and uh you know just looking back it feels
like you know um we had models that predicted
um cases that were far from reality and far from
things that emerged you know we had at in the in
two extreme conditions too I mean we had models
that predicted that there will be millions of
death in just a few months just at the beginning
of the pandemic and there were also models that
predicted that by May 2020 everything will
end and we'll be back to normal life and
none of these happen so apparently pandemic
forecasting was very difficult as a result some
of these Scholars have suggested that just this
is probably impossible or very hard to do it is
because of always is not necessarily because
of lack of data but it's just the nature of
um exponential growth that you see in these
situations with a little bit um deviation at the
beginning you end up with a different trajectory
so maybe that's the reason that is hard to do you
ask a little bit different questions that you know
if we can just look at a sample of models about
covid-19 and explore which ones are doing better
and what model features makes them better models
maybe we can bring insights into better developing
better forecasting models maybe we can have better
models better use of data to provide a better
long-term pandemic many of you are aware of this
fundamental building block of many um epidemic
models which is seir model it goes back to 100
years ago and the basic logic is that when you
want to model the spirit of the disease you divide
the population to specific groups susceptibles
expose infected and then removed and then you have
different feedback loops but especially the one
that infected individuals resulting more exposure
and then with this positive feedback look you end
up um having it you know more and more spread of
the disease and then you know at some point you
run out of susceptibles and then that's where the
um the Finish we are finished with it with the
epidemic but when you simulate these models you
usually have two different modes of behavior one
of them is exponential growth and then saturation
is like an s-shaped curve I mean obviously
with different slopes but the the figure look
um very similar at least qualitatively the other
mode is that you know depending the pandemic
doesn't emerge and at the beginning with the you
know R naught of less than one you just never
um have rise in cases so there are two different
modes of behavior if you look at Active cases you
see one kind of um pumped in number of cases
and then it goes down and we are done there
are several uh extension to this model obviously
in the past 100 years and these extensions are
in different directions especially in increasing
the number of carbon partners and those kind of
boxes that you see in the picture you know what
if we divide are infected to asymptomatic versus
symptomatic you know what if we um add you
know another uh stock variable for people who
are in hospital and so on so there are different
directions and but there are also limitations to
these models you know and people have been dealing
with that so these are the common behaviors that
you see on the left hand and then the if you look
at the data the data looks like looks differently
this is data from the United States and as you
see until you know October 2021 it is not just
one you know bell-shaped here in terms of cases
but you see oscillation oscillation in cases
oscillation in confirmed cases oscillation
confirmed death and even not a constant test
coverage number of people that are tested are diff
are changing over time and that also influences
how many confirmed cases you have so not a regular
essay curve not a bell-shaped curve oscillatory
patterns in data and change in observations over
time this is not just us you look at all around
the world and you see different sorts of behavior
again you know oscillation exists in many parts of
the world but you know with different frequency or
a period of oscillation and different magnitude of
oscillations all these and graphs are normalized
to the population so you can actually compare uh
the y-axis to and as you see you know in
the in Peru and Chile we have big numbers
for daily cases and death then you know we end
up with South Korea and New Zealand with lower
number of cases per million of population so you
have a range of behaviors and it is a little bit
too much to expect from scr models to predict
and and produce all these branches of behavior
so what can be done to have a better
model for to have a better forecast
this is our study design so we take advantage
of this data set that exists in CDC so CDC in
April 2020 so early in the pandemic
created this fantastic forecast hop
which many modelers submitted their projections
in that Hub and on a weekly basis so every week
and very experienced modelers very good teams
we're submitting their projections their model
based projections about how many cases or how many
deaths we will have in the next weeks on a weekly
basis so you would predict predict next week that
two weeks later that three weeks later then so
some time Horizon and you would submit to this
forecast also there's this huge data set there
based on how models have been broadcasting and
we focused on models that forecast death there
were 61 models that they were providing forecast
and it is not just National level actually many
of them were for specific locations and 57 kind
of specific location in the US you can recognize
that there were projections for them on a weekly
basis and we picked this one year period which was
around the time that we started this research and
the and these models you know some of them were
forecasting like one to four weeks ahead and some
of them were providing a long European forecasting
which was interesting so you are dealing with a
huge number of data points in terms of forecasts
about half a million data parts that are coming
from these 60 models for very for a big sample of
regions not just with one sample and over a year
so it's not just one bumping number of cases but
capturing the oscillation so there is this data
and we thought that okay we can start by studying
the approaches of that these modelers have used
in their models look at their Reports look at the
articles that are coming out of this and analyze
if there is association between model architecture
assumptions that exist in the model approaches
that these modelers have taken and then accuracy
of the forecast you know remember that that half
a million data points that we have time has passed
and we actually have now the correct value
of Def so we can calculate the error in those
predictions and see if there is any association
between model architecture or p60 models and how
accurately have been in their forecast and
then if we can extract the main insights and
build a simple model we can kind of compare
and validate that model using this analysis
model categories that we recognize early on by
looking at these very these four big groups you
may have mechanistic compartments on model
it's very similar to the slide that you saw
at the beginning so it follows the logic of
using compartments stocks for how people are
divided into a different population you often use
differential equation to formulate those models
another category is non-mechanistic models which
has been growing especially recently with machine
learning techniques regression techniques so the
idea is that you're not simulating the mechanics
of how the disease spreads many times you have a
black box model that has inputs and outputs so the
goal is to have a better prediction of from for
those outputs and and improve your model over time
you have a third category which is Ensemble
models many modelers have multiple models
and which can be mechanistic or non-mechanistic
and just they combine the results either they
look at the mean of forecasts or median
forecast and use that as the output of
their forecasted so technically Ensemble models
are also kind of combination of mechanistic and
non-mechanistic models the other fourth
category others and we were hoping to see
more agent-based models there but it turned out
that there were only two agent-based models and
they didn't continue projecting I'm assuming
that that's because of the high computational
expensiveness of these type of models in
simple words it takes time to project and
if you want to submit your projections on a
weekly base probably it's not that feasible
we went through all the documents that exist
in these models and not all models are well
documented so there is a variation in terms of
how documents are provided but we looked for
what are the variables that you're considering
your model what are their approaches for using
data in your model is the data and
input to the model or it is used for
model calibration and can be you
know fixing model with the data
and what are the outputs of these models
are they projecting death cases and into
what time Horizon they are considering their
forecast one important question was that how
transmission intensity or reproduction number
is modeled here you know sometimes people use
simplistic assumptions and you with a constant
number but sometimes you have a more advanced
um approach and try to model it explicitly or
implicitly in the model and try to kind of predict
how transmission is going to change over time
especially for the future transmission it becomes
important that are we assuming that from now on
the disease will have the same reproduction number
or is going to change as people's behavior changes
finally stage we're sending is is the idea that
um how they are dealing with errors in their
estimations and in their calibrations there are
Advanced methods like common filtering that we try
to filter for all the noises that you have in your
um in your simulation to have better estimations
of your parametrics so how advanced are these
calibration methods in terms of Mobility there
was uh this interesting Trend in in models that
many try to actually include that has inputs to
their model so it is a representation of human
behavior so how that was done in the model
that was a question that we dealt with you
know are they modeling how people change their
Mobility or we are using data and data goes as
an input to the model rather than having a having
Mobility as a function of other state variables
in addition you know we gathered data about
modelers affiliation your disciplinary and
where they're coming you know is it from industry
or Academia and the availability of technical
documents and so on you looked at other factors
specifically in each group of modeling for example
in mechanistic models that have you know the ones
that had enough documentation you can look at the
the level to which these models are are you
know provide a detailed representation of the
spread of the disease is that just three state
variable sir or suir or it is way more detailed
are they like age structures or included in
those models or no they are all considered
um kind of an average and aggregate and you
know are they considering weather impacts in
their mechanistic models similar questions
were raised about non-mechanistic models
you know what is the approach again is that a
regression model is that a machine learning model
and the same you know do they consider weather
impact and Ensemble model you know which type
of models they have included so these are all
coding so according this coding it is more like
a qualitative work that you go through all the
documents and analyze it and see how they have
done the job and the quantitative part was
about analyzing the forecast errors and kind
of finding you know how the errors are emerging
and then finding associations between what you
are seeing in a model structure and the amount of
error that they have had in their projections our
first round of results is just analysis of these
these models first let's look at the distribution
of the models this is how you see in different
categories mechanistic models are kind of the
majority of the models that we see in this in this
sample non-mechanistic models they're actually
producing you know a kind of a considerable
fraction of the models about 38 of the model is
very non-mechanistic and Ensemble model is around
like 12 percent of the models they're Ensemble
models under the category of mechanistic models
you can divide the models into different groups
we divided them to compartments all with Stage
resetting and without a stage resetting and agent
based model so agent-based models are actually
individual and as I said there are only two
models in that category and they didn't continue
projecting after a while but in compartmental
models we had models that had more sophisticated
methods of dealing with noise in data and trying
to kind of filter for those noise and the ones
that kind of took you a more simplestic approach
so these are categories of models that we observed
after coding the data then we plot the error that
we see in their projections B and x-axis here
is prediction Horizon so week one is the error
that you're producing when you are projecting
next week um week two is amount of error that
you're producing when you're projecting week two
and uh y-axis here is the relative error so it's
not absolute error but we are comparing the error
that each of the category of these models have
with a constant model so that's our Baseline and
constant model was is the simplest model that you
can have as a naive model it the Assumption in
a constant model is that whatever death is today
depth of code is today that's going to continue
for 14 weeks so we are not changing the numbers
we are just going with whatever today is so that's
the simplest model that you can have and we pick
that and compare the errors that you get from
each of these categories with that constant model
let's just focus on red line and blue line and
the red line is those non-mechanistic models
like regression models machine learning models
and the blue line are those compartmental models
that are differential equations like
SAR models but with no stage resetting
as you see in short term Redline is doing better
lower error but in long term blue line is doing
better so it appears that carefitting approaches
in the red line are good at providing short-term
predictions but probably they are overfitting
and in long term you're getting lots of error
in our projections in contrast the blue line
was doing bad in short term but in long term
because it was probably capturing the mechanics
of the spread of the disease it had limited
um kind of future projections and it was providing
some more insights about future projections
but what was better than all of these were
compartmental models that had a stage resetting
too so either that's about stage resetting so the
benefits of dealing with noises in data and kind
of trying to filter them or just people who were
doing these type of filtering techniques they were
actually better modelers and their models ended up
having lower errors over the long range too these
are average of errors that you get from each these
categories so we did lots of regression analysis
and and all these results and insights are robust
and um and a few other things that you know you
would find is that um well not no academic models
are barely better if at all from non-academic
models and you know there are like a few things
for example you know that constant model wasn't
doing that bad you know when you compare with
some of these groups and there's a reason for
that I will discuss why in long term you're you're
getting some benefits from that naive assumption
that will have the same level of death in the
future but these are the first layer of results
that you get from this analysis and if I want to
list a few other insights that we got after kind
of analyzing all these models in at the individual
level is that first in long-term projections
mechanic mechanistic models we're performing
better than non-mechanistic models or care fitting
models so that was obvious in the previous
graph the second point was that the models
that captured transmission rate they did a better
forecast you know change in transmission rate so
models that are modeling or considering the fact
that reproduction number or the speed of spread
of the disease may change in the future as human
behavior changes they are doing a better job in
their forecast the ones that are assuming whatever
the transmission rate is today that's how things
will evolve in the future this is how the virus
is behaving they are doing a worse projection in
the future so that was one of the interesting
things that we found one of these models were
actually endogenously modeling transmission
rate the logic was simple the models were
assuming that if death rate per million you know
passes some threshold the government is going to
have more lockdown measures or similar measures
which will decrease transmission rate so they
had built this assumption for their future
projection as they were projecting they had
this mechanism in their model that your death
rate is going to increase in this model there
will be some intervention by government future
to decrease that by decreasing transmission
this is endogenously modeling and transmission
rate a few good models included weather impact
and stator setting looks like helpful based on
the past graph so the question is that um so
these are associations right like how good really
they are can we do a little experiment and see
you know kind of you know control things
and see are they really improving in the
um benefits that you get from forecast
so let's just build the simplest model
that you can have and only include these uh four
features and see if that model does any better
so we start with the simplest possible model
is scir and we add a behavioral feedback loop
to that which captures endogenous change
in transmission rate if cases and death
increases you're assuming that people's risk
perception will increase and that means that
they will involve they will do some kind of
measures they will definitely involved in
some preventive measures that will decrease
Transmission in future and as death declines
they will feel more relaxed and they will go more
outside which can increase the transmission rate
the statory setting is simple I will talk about
that and impact of bitter is was it published
paper by our team when we just included that
effect marginal effect on our projection to
see how how much that really helps and we exclude
many other important factors that one should not
exclude when they are doing a forecasting job
and the reason is that we want to keep this as
simple as possible and look at those features
things that are excluded are like testing or
travel or even asymptomatic versus symptomatic
you know vaccination rate and all those things
changing uh IFR you know and the fact that you
know hospitals are learning and improving their
operations and kind of decreasing death rate or
adherence you know you see that you know people
are getting tired of Kobe and they want to go
out that's also important so we exclude all
these things in the estimation side we go with the
most simple assumptions you know we for example
you know many parameters we don't estimate them
we just get them from papers so to decrease the
um degrees of freedom that this model have and
focus on things that we really care in terms of
those you know mechanisms that you're exploring
this is a simple scir model as you saw in the
previous slide so if you want to show it in a
diagram what we have done to this model is this
so we are adding one feedback so the rate at which
people are removing from infected individuals to
uh to remove a fraction of them are dying and you
can calculate that by infection and fatality rate
you get number of death so we want to represent
that if that just increases people will have some
risk response their perception of risk increases
that decreases their activities and contact
trade which will decrease transmission intensity
right so for that mechanism you just take the the
calculate like death so that's delayed death and
if that's increasing based on the equation that
you see there it's it if that increases inversely
affects transmission rate which means that it
decreases that so this is the the main equation
that we add to that kind of conventional SAR model
and so we have a few parameters that now we want
to um calibration estimate them in this analysis
they would be beta not you know the the initial
transmission intensity Patient Zero Internet you
know arrival to the system you know when is the
disease is going to start in this region and uh
and other factors you know like um time that it
takes for people to adjust their risk perception
so that lag to death what is the delay for that
which can be different for different societies
in terms of a stage resetting again you know we
try to be very simple there are more Advanced
Techniques and and we didn't do that so we
went with a very heuristic uh and and and
cheap in terms of computation um that you know
when we are projecting a trend at the time of
projection we are considering you know the error
at the date of projection you know whatever death
today is you know if our model is uh predicting
a little bit less or a little bit High we try to
um correct for that error but then the rest
of the simulation goes as it was um working
let's look at the performance of this simple
model so remember that all these 61 models in
in the covet Hub they are very Advanced and very
good quality models many of them are high quality
models and are developed by a very good modeler so
there are so many kind of interesting features and
so many achievements there what we want to do
here is just to look at like how this model is
um that is learning from those models and
capturing the essential kind of useful mechanisms
that those have can it really kind of in
performance also show it performance as comparable
Wendy project so we use uh past you know that
duration of time in our projections of use like
past data and then project and and then you know
in the same time we can also calculate the error
that we have in our projection because things have
happened right so at the time of projection we are
not using any future data but we start projecting
and then we calculate the error so what would have
been our error if this was our projections so we
do that for 57 regions in the United States and in
this picture adds up all the projections so in the
first glance it it looks like the simple model can
create oscillation in data it's not perfect
there are places that you know in those red
circles show time of projections again just
examples so we can create oscillations with this
and sometimes you know as kind of error is bigger
than expected but overall you see the patterns
then we calculate errors on projection Horizon
so we have done all these projections with the
model for different regions let's just add up all
errors per capita and compare the performance that
you would get from this model with other models
and the model that is hard to beat is covet cdc's
covet Hub um ensemble projection so a fascinating
thing about cdc's covet hot is that um if you if
you get all this data and look at the median of
um of projections you actually get a pretty good
prediction and that's the blue line here so it
appears that this simple model can do a better
job that hard to beat Ensemble model in this um
in this group of models which was very interesting
so when you saw that this model does a pretty
good job in terms of projection and the error
is lower then you started um turning off all these
features and see which one is actually helping us
so first we turned off the effect of weather
is that helping us that's marginally helping us
and as you see there is a uh there's uh there is a
graph that is you know has a higher error or still
better than the Ensemble model but um but you
know adding bitter effect is marginally helping
us State resetting was helping in short-term
forecast but not in long-term forecasts so
that's kind of taking care of the early errors but
what was the most benefit uh beneficial feature of
this model was that feedback loop so the worst
case here that you see with the line and star on
it is our model when you turn off the uh response
the behavioral response and that and you suddenly
get a huge error worse than most models and
More Than The Ensemble model so apparently that
feedback is what is mainly making this work a a
good predictor then we compared the projection of
this model which each individual model that
you have in this group of models you have
um you know you had we started the 61 models not
all of them are projecting and running and then
kind of regular basis so with this if you rank
them based on the error that you're creating you
end off of this graph and our model is uh the
black line that is bold and you see that during
the first four weeks we are among the top 10 but
then after a while it moves higher and provides
you know as the second um in projection the the
one that is uh constantly higher is a very good
model has you know capturing many details many
interesting details about the spread of the
diseases computationally way more advanced and
has much more detail but importantly that's the
one that has the feedback so it's the one that
was assuming that if in projection projecting
death number of death passes some threshold in
the future again there will be some interventions
from the government so that's the model that
actually is doing a great job in this set
use all other measures again to compute our
model with with these models and this is
error that each model is creating in comparison
to the constant model that I said at the beginning
that you know assumes um death as as constant
you see that you know there are several models
that are doing better than that model
and um and um but you know that model
is not also a necessarily bad model and and I
will mention the the reason that that's doing
um an interesting performance so the point
here is that mechanistic models you know when
you narrow down to um more kind of important
structures and avoid overfitting it helps you
simple model is helping here so this is the
lesson that we are learning from this analysis and
what is important in expanding sqr models is the
feedback loop not necessarily the compartments
so most focus is around increasingly compartments
increasing the details in in compartmental models
however many times you get the most benefit
by including behavioral impact how people are
responding to change in state variables and that
suddenly gives you um and improves your models you
know we learn other things in this analysis like
how you can get wrong conclusion if you just focus
on one region projecting one region or projecting
at one time period or projecting only for one
um one wave of the disease these are these
you know from data analysis perspective it
is very important to have a big sample
of regions to have a long sample of
um of data points in terms of like different
waves of the disease you know sometimes you're
good at in one way but not in the other one so
we should all expand these data source data um
extension and that will help you to have to really
help you know what makes a Model A Better model
so let me just get back to the model this was the
simplest model that you can have you know kind of
conventional model this is what we add this is the
behavioral response that you are adding to this
model making that data endogenous so how important
this model is I just focused on forecasting but it
appears that this behavioral feedback has many
more benefits it's not just forecasting it can
help you in in in many directions and it can
provide unique insights about several puzzles
that have been dealing during the pandemic and I
want to kind of briefly mention that the art all
documented in this commentary in um in bmj uh
Global health so if we call that feedback loop
a risk driven response so the assumption is that
as death increases people to receive higher risk
and they respond on that changes the spread of
the disease if you include that it can explain
several puzzles one of them is Convergence of
reproduction number to one so this is one of
the interesting observations that some of us had
when you look at the data points of the spread
of the disease across different nations across
different regions one of the interesting thing
and challenging thing is that you see that
these res are all around one you know just uh
ignoring the first few months of the pandemic
which was at the beginning and our zero was high
and the disease was spreading after a while
R is converging around one and many people
actually misinterpreted that as heard immunity
early on you know we are we are we are finishing
with the disease but that wasn't the case there
was this convergence to one and the question was
why this is happening and it is not just the
average re you know if you look at countries
each kind of then we looked at that like about
140 countries their average remain between 0.9
and 1.1 so it is not changing that much why is
that happening you know why are e converged to
one why that equilibrium emerged so that can be
explained by this feedback remember that when re
reproduction number is above one that means that
the spread of the disease continues to increase
right so if the number of cases are increasing and
that corresponds to increasing number of death at
some point eventually people will say well this is
getting out of hand you should do something right
right and then they do sufficient reaction that's
the point that they are decreasing re until re
becomes below 1. so re cannot be above one for a
long time at some point we will have a behavioral
reaction but what if our ego is very low if our
ego is very low then cases Decline and Decline and
Decline and at some point people will say what is
the point of all these social distancing this is
very costly and I'm tired of that and I want to
go and interact with people so re can't go very
low either and if it goes very low again people
will interact and will increase that above so in
this feedback loop is resulting in convergence
of re21 without necessarily actually resulting
inherit immunity so it's not because we are
running out of um susceptible individuals but
because people are adjusting their behaviors based
on cases or based on risk perception so this is
the first puzzle the second is about the waves of
the pandemic you know it is a good question that
why do we have these ways in the disease where are
they coming from why do we have oscillation if you
think about this feedback that was introduced here
from a system science perspective or from control
theory perspective it is a negative feedback it's
the balancing feedback loop and in that theory we
know that for to have oscillation you have to
have a negative feedback loop with at least two
stock variables or two level variables to create
oscillation it is necessary not sufficient but you
need to have that so this mechanism is creating
and can create oscillation and we observe that in
our simulation too so this is one of the reasons
for observe waves of the pandemic early on again
you know if you read the papers during the
pandemic many people were kind of trying to
find reasons of oscillations and usually the
hypotheses are around waning immunity which is
correct reigning immunity can create oscillation
but then not quickly I mean it will take to see
that pattern and the effect and the in creating
waves it takes I know the rent the the duration
of uh or the period of oscillation that you would
see from waning immunity was not matching the
waves that we were seeing from covid-19 especially
early on in the pandemic or new variants they can
create oscillations seasonal patterns can create
oscillation and other behavioral mechanisms
so this was an additional explanation
about how you get waves in in a pandemic
the third one is that you see mortality variants
in different countries why different countries
have different um different depth and that can't
be easily explained by many other variables and
but consider that again feedback loop so the
question is that at what level of depth you will
be convinced to have stronger measures to control
the society if culturally and if economically
we have different thresholds or reaction to
number yeah that's the resulting variation in
um in the level of the level of mortality that
you've seen in these cases so my colleague has
written a paper on this and they analyze and
show that there's a good correlation between
how responsive the society or that region is
to to death and number of death that they have
so that better explains the correlation this four
item is the one that I presented today and how it
helps enhancing forecasting or the puzzle of why
forecasting models are failing the fifth puzzle
was about vaccine prioritization you may remember
that you know many models kind of argued that
um given the high mortality of elderly it might
be optimal to start vaccination from elderly and
these are coming again from models that don't
have this behavioral feedback loop there so if
you expand our idea our model to models of
different age groups and how the behavioral
feedback there but consider that different aging
groups have different behavioral responses because
their risk of dying is different then suddenly
your optimal solution for vaccination changes
so it is not just the fact that younger
individuals may have more interactions but
also the fact that their responsiveness to death
might be different than um all elderly because
they are less likely to die I mean they have less
risk in as related to uh to covet um 19. and the
intuition here is is interesting just assume that
you have two groups one is um less responsive to
um kind of overall risk one is more responsive
if you are vaccinating the one that is more
responsive right first then the disease is still
spreading and and the death is decreasing the
ones that are more responsive are high risk so
if the death overall will will decrease which
would increase everybody's interaction too but if
you start from vaccinating the ones that are less
likely to die you're actually building a herd
immunity and it's still the one that are more
responsive are have a higher risk perception so
they are taking care of themselves while you are
also building hair in unity and suddenly um you
you end up with an optimal solution that uh the
society you know in general is is building
paired immunity and the cases are declining
finally the concept of endemic that these days
especially you are thinking about it so what is
this and then make you know where that can happen
you know what what is the meaning of endemic
and and if you think again in terms of the
feedback loop that was introduced so it it
means that the risks are declining or our
perception of risk is has declined so it is
related to reduced number of cases as everybody
is thinking about that it is related to lower
fatality rate which is about vaccination about
treatment but it is also about tolerance of risk
and how people are and kind of responding to the
risks that they see or in simple word endemic is
when people say that the risk is not big enough
for me to change my behavior and I can go to the
normal life so the risk is when this feedback loop
loses its power and that's when we come to the
normal life so the implication here is a state of
endemic is an epidemiological and disease-related
construct but it's also a behavioral construct so
it also relates to how we perceive risks so it is
different for different regions because of how
the disease is present but also it is different
because of how people of different you know
different regions may have different responses
different sensitivities to the risk so it is
also a behavioral construct that you see here
so this is my presentation thank you
I'll be happy to answer questions
Naveed thank you so much that was fascinating um
I had I have several questions here so um firstly
clearly scr R models are going to be insufficient
because as you rightly point out they don't
really factor into the behavior of the individual
elements that go into the modeling the thing one
being trying to model is the interaction between
the the the people or you know the the sample
subjects I guess that are being represented in the
model um but it doesn't take into account their
behavior and yet of course the scrr models it also
involve first order partial differential equations
or differential equations I guess they're not
partial they're just ordinarily differential
equations are some of your modeling is it do you
feel that it the one of the net results of this
is that those models should be kind of looked
at and revised to be made higher order to take
into account higher order differential factors
which might be better reflective of behavior
so that that's a very good point it is this is
true that seirs uh have limited you know capacity
to to represent you know the spread of the disease
especially when human behavior is important which
was the case of covet 19. so the question is that
how you can expand that so you have a model of
disease in the spread of the disease but there is
also human change in human behavior one approach
was that people use the same scir and for human
behavior they eat data like they get Mobility
data and they feed it to the model changing
transmission rate that's okay for fitting the past
data it is not okay for projecting because you
don't know how people will change their Mobility
you don't know how people will change their
behavior you don't have data for their future all
right so that's the limitation that they have when
you use scir and feed Behavior as an exogenous
variable or as time series as Mobility time series
which is the very common approach these days
another way to fix and extend this area as you
were going in that direction is to add a modeling
feature to that and model human behavior so
this presentation that I had was the first
step modeling just risk response so that's a very
simple response that you know human can have the
assumption is that death Rises I feel higher risk
perception and I decrease my activity and that
that declines I will increase my activity because
I have a lower risk perception that's the simplest
one but if I want to kind of build on your ideas
there are there are other things that you can add
and get more and more complicated models for
example kobit fatigue or adherence fatigue
that means that you know as you decrease your
activities you're accumulating this social or
psychological construct which is fatigue and you
get tired and at some point you may actually say
that despite the risk I can't do this anymore
or you may say that despite the risk I I need
to earn money so I need to work right so that also
is a behavioral or economic construct that comes
in place so yes you know SAR models in their
traditional format are not adequate the focus
on just expanding compartments is not helping
to focus on including data exogenously to the
models is not helping the way to move forward is
to build coupled disease Behavior models where
you are actually modeling human behavior as a
function of different variables in your system
I imagine that those models would become
non-linear and be very interesting mathematically
to examine the behavior of and one of the things
which I also was fascinated by with your modeling
that you've just presented is that you've
included the weather as a potential variable
um and it was just reminded me of the old joke
that lots of people talk about the weather but
nobody's doing anything about it in your in your
case you're able to go and put the put the weather
in as a factor and see whether or not it changes
or take the weather out I'm curious if there are
other weather-like variables that may affect human
behavior that might also be suitable for inclusion
in models like this and I was thinking of like the
stock market if we were all locked down but the
stock market was just going you know crazy and you
know the Dow Jones Industrial index was you know
at all-time highs it might affect our individual
behavior I'm curious if you have given any
thought to other weather-like models that might be
important and that's also very interesting point
um my first thought would be that the difference
between weather and and and the stock market is
the same thing that you said that we we don't do
anything about weather right we talk about it and
you know I I know that you know even weather is
endogenous with all these global warming issues
so we are we are changing the weather too but at
least in the time Horizon of our analysis whether
it's exogenous but the stock market economy is
getting feedback from the interactions that we
have in the society and and the state of the
disease is influencing our economic activity
so a good model would be a coupled disease economy
model that would include this as a feedback loop
that would be that would be very exciting to see
again that would probably add non-linearities to
the to the system that would mean how you model
it would make it very interesting make interesting
predictions that's for sure but on the other hand
it may also be sensitive to initial conditions
which is kind of again where there could be a lot
of science to be explored one of the things which
I I think that you touched on which I thought was
really interesting is the the topic of mortality
of variance and just how much mortality one
is willing to accept before there's sort of
a policy either a behavioral change at the level
of the individual or policy change at the level
of a community or a society and I'm curious about
things that we're seeing now for example in China
where there was an initial policy of you know
zero exposure we're not going to let anybody
you know expose anybody else and now we're seeing
sort of the the knock-on effect of that that they
waited so long that now people who if they go
out in the world at all they're being exposed
and now you're just seeing what's running rampant
through that Community is that something that some
of these models might have been able to forecast
so that that's a very important point and again
it is about the complexity of the situation that
we are dealing with so on one hand we know that
um responsiveness to the state of disease
is important if you are more responsive
you can better control the disease the
spread of the disease but on the other hand
and one thing that is underestimated is that you
are accumulating adherence fatigue right and at
some point that fatigue will kind of um pass
its own threshold and then we cannot tolerate
it anymore and we want to go out right we will
say well this is the two extreme policy you want
to go out and in that instead now the question
is that are we vaccinated enough or dealing with
this new condition you know very balanced in
our NPI and pharmaceutical interventions all
together right when that thing happens re in
vaccine wise are we prepared to deal with that
and then with new variants you know we all know
that all these behavioral reactions decrease the
spread of disease by some percentage right
if you decrease it by like 30 or 40 percent
and you end up with a mutation that is way
more kind of has a much higher or not than
the the level of kind of control that
we have might not be sufficient for
the new variants so there are all these
complexities that come and play a role here
absolutely Navid what are some final thoughts
on the role for data science in trying to do
forecasting to draw from data to apply it to
in this case epidemiological Trends and human
behavior where what do data scientists need to
know in order to be able to utilize tools like
this and to to work in this space um I think
there's a there's a huge value in in using
um kind of benefiting from what is emerging
so obviously with these new opportunities to
have access to huge data sources you know this
um covet models that we use and access that we
had to always and availability of data
these are all important so I think the
role of data science is is increasing but
personally you know as a modeler I I like
to have these two hand in hand and use data to
improve models and use models to have a better
sense of what type of data I should look at
so kind of rather than just using Computing
approaches and looking it as a black box
I like to see it mechanistically I like
to think about Rules of Nature and like how
things are connected and how things evolve
and then use that when I'm exploring the questions
so there was a great opportunity to use data
but also we should open our eyes and look at
mechanisms and and and and systems in white box
way too and see how the Logics of the system is
working the other lesson that I learned in this
paper and actually the credit goes to my co-author
is that if you expand the regions and expand your
sample in different directions you know expand
the regions expand the time Horizon so you try to
have many many different conditions in your test
that really helps you to to be more confident in
the results that you're finding so not being
narrow-minded but kind of extending it to
different regions and that's now possible because
of all these advancement in data science so you
don't have to just take a simple Trend and from a
country and then look at that or symbol you know
time period you can do your analysis use using a
very large sample of cases models regions and and
kind of be more confident in the results that
you're finding or make your results more valid
thank you so much this has really been wonderful
um a very impressive amount of work I I really
have enjoyed chatting with you so thank you so
much and thank you to everyone who's uh watching
on YouTube and who's joined us here on zoom and uh
we wish you a very good weekend and we'll
see you next week thank you again Navid